[Music]
responsibility
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i was the snowflake consultant on the
movie frozen
they wanted to get all the snowflakes
right and so they asked me you know how
they grow and i was very pleased when
the movie came out they all looked like
real snowflakes none of them were
eight-sided they were all six-sided and
so good job
my name is kenley bricht and i'm a
professor of physics here at caltech
and i also grow snowflakes
well i got into physics very early i've
been doing that most of my life maybe
about 20 years ago i just got interested
in how crystals grow and that sort of
led me to ice and to snowflakes we still
don't exactly understand why they look
like they do so it's kind of fun to
think about
to make a snowflake in the lab you start
with water and water vapor you've got to
get everything cold and basically start
a crystal growing and i'll kind of blow
moist air down onto it and it just
absorbs water vapor from the air and
starts to grow and i can do this on a
piece of glass and so just watch it grow
i'm the only one that makes snowflakes
like this in the lab
when you start to look really carefully
at how a snowflake works
you find you don't understand it and
there's a lot going on you dig deeper
there's more and more stuff and it's
it's really very interesting to me
anyway
i love to go out and and sort of hunt
for snowflakes because these beautiful
works of art are just falling all over
and you pick a few of them up and
photograph them and the rest of them you
just trample on at the end of the day
i'm trying to understand how atoms and
molecules fit together to form crystals
and by studying snowflakes slowly you
figure things out that are that are
useful
one snowflake at a time
[Music]
chemistry explains literally everything
that is happening around you the dry ice
is taking the thermal energy from the
water unfortunately i instantaneously
get judged on my appearance that is very
frustrating for me so i'm going to pick
up my hot water i'm going to come over
here and i'm going to throw it right
into my bucket okay it means i have to
work harder but at the end it is so so
incredibly worth it and one
[Music]
my name is dr kate bieberdorf and i am a
lecturer at the university of texas at
austin
[Music]
i'm trying to break the stigma of what a
stereotypical scientist looks like so my
thing is i am not wearing a bow tie i'm
not wearing suspenders i don't have some
frumpy cardigan on i'm just some regular
girl who likes to play with fire and i
also really like designer shoes and
that's okay as the alginate hits the
calcium chloride the alginate would
prefer to be with the two plus charged
calcium instead of the one plus charged
sodium and what happens
is we form gummy worms doesn't matter
what you look like any human can be a
scientist
[Music]
i definitely try to use energy and
excitement i love this one
i do my best to try to reach students
that might be intimidated by science i
use anything that will make the 483
students sit up straight and actually
listen to the words coming out of your
mouth
as soon as i've exploded something in
their face i have their attention for
just 60 seconds and i can do whatever i
can to shove that knowledge right into
their brains
okay so what we're gonna do today is
doing some chemistry we're gonna do
three different hands-on experiments i
find chemistry to be an incredibly
challenging topic pour your water pour
your water beautiful now keep watching
keep watching i'm so sick of the
stereotypical female scientists and we
can do things other than biology by the
way chemistry physics engineering we can
do it look at what you made the fact
that i've been able to master it but
then use science to start the
conversation but then physically stand
there and break that image it's the most
rewarding thing i could ever do ever
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is justin schmidt yeah my name is
justin schmidt he's an entomologist and
i'm an entomologist
i basically study stinging insects
[Music]
he's been stung by a lot of insects
i've probably been stung at least a
thousand times he reviews insect stings
the way a sommelier reviews wine pure
intense brilliant pain like walking over
flaming charcoal with a three inch snail
embedded in your heel which insect was
that that's the bullet ant
this is his lab in tucson
[Music]
this is his harvester ant
this is his vinegaroon
this is his tarantula hawk
these are some more harvester ants in a
park near his lab
he is the creator of the schmidt pain
scale this schmidt pain scale is
basically a scale to rate the
painfulness of stinging insects on a
scale of one to four a one would be a
sweat bee two would be something like a
yellow jacket wasp the three would be
something like a harvest strand and a
four would be a tarantula hawk
how bad is a four
four it's absolutely excruciatingly
debilitating incapacitating just shuts
you down just absolute sheer
pain there's just nothing you can really
do about that
i don't think i'd want to be stung by a
whole bunch of different fours i don't
think i could endure that for very long
let's be clear justin schmidt doesn't
just go out and get stung on purpose
it's just that he's dedicated his life
to studying well my passion is insects
and stinging insects in particular yeah
i get stung but that's that's all just
part of the passion you know that that
gives me data you know sting
helps me in understanding what the
insects doing
i get to be out in the sunshine and out
in the rain out in the environment
studying these magnificent beautiful
insects it's just just such a joy
i can't imagine anything i'd rather do
more
[Music]
you're not supposed to worry about how
the clocks got set right they just did
get said
when everything's working properly and
i'm doing my job
you don't know anything about it
are you wearing a watch yeah i don't
wear a watch because it's too compulsive
that's judah levine it makes you look at
the watch all the time and you kind of
go a little crazy his nickname is
literally the nation's time lord i mean
that comes from doctor who all right if
you know if you've ever watched doctor
who i don't remember who made me the
time lord i think it's unfair to all my
colleagues
okay do you have a tardis uh no i don't
have a tardis okay only doctor who has
the tardis okay fair enough but there's
a reason he got that nickname judah's
job is to officially keep time standard
he works here at the national institute
of standards and technology it's a
government agency that maintains
standards of all quantities such as
length speed and well
time in the old days
which means like 100 years ago
time was something that was astronomical
it was sunrise or sunset or noon or
whatever in the more modern era time is
something defined by atomic clocks which
provide a very stable reference
frequency atomic clocks are the most
accurate way to tell time on earth
45 years ago judah and a team of
scientists at nist developed a system
for the atomic clock that tracks time
more accurately than ever before in the
u.s linking all phones power grids
financial markets you name it every day
he checks to make sure the systems are
calibrated ensuring that time is right
on schedule these are the atomic clocks
this is the real stuff okay
what if we switched off the atomic clock
what if it just stops working
certainly cell phone systems stop pretty
much right away the internet stops
pretty quickly high-end tech stuff would
suffer very quickly but that's probably
not going to happen there are 400 atomic
clocks
in many timing laboratories i don't
think we're ever going to intentionally
switch off all of the atomic clocks i
mean that's
uh i know that's an unthinkable event
if you say so judah after all you're the
reason we all know what time it is
[Music]
[Music]
you